Jake:叫了吗
Jake: Did you call?
Jake:带上了吗
Jake: Did you bring it?
Jake:先先戴上啊
Jake: Put it on first.
Jake:容量
Jake: Capacity.
Jake:一个t的音盘不知道含剩多少
Jake: I don't know how much is left on a 1TB drive.
Jake:怎么的
Jake: What's up?
Shure: 要不要先把那些数据先倒
Shure: Should we transfer the data first?
Jake:哪些数据
Jake: What data?
Jake:就那个FD
Jake: The FD one.
Jake:那你下午几点钟能用
Jake: What time can you use it in the afternoon?
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Jake:哦懂了
Jake: Oh, got it.
Jake:我Mac也可以插USB
Jake: My Mac can also connect to USB.
Jake:啊那那那是用我Mac
Jake: Ah, then use my Mac.
Jake:不是说导Mac呢还是说什么
Jake: Were you talking about transferring to the Mac or what?
Jake:哦哦哦我看看
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, let me see.
Jake:还有多大啊
Jake:今天该吃什么了
Jake: What should we eat today?
Shure: 吃什么葡萄啊
Shure: Eat grapes or what?
Jake:很满
Jake: It's full.
Jake:要帮忙吗
Jake: Need help?
Alice:没事拧开了
Alice: No, I got it open.
Alice:谢谢，不是拧开
Alice: Thanks, it wasn't opening.
Alice:自己开了
Alice: Got it myself.
Alice:要来一半吗
Alice: Want half?
Jake:就来一小半
Jake: Just a little half.
Jake:谢谢不用谢
Jake: Thanks, no need to thank.
Jake:昨天发烧了吗
Jake: Did you have a fever yesterday?
Jake:困吗但我有点头疼
Jake: Tired? But I have a headache.
Jake:头疼困困肯定会困
Jake: Headache and tired, definitely tired.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Jake:准备戴个眼镜吧
Jake: Get ready to wear glasses.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:哦没关系没关系没关系
Jake: Oh, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Jake:这个先放地这吧
Jake: Put this on the ground first.
Jake:对对对开就行
Jake: Yeah, yeah, just open it.
Jake:害怕吗嗯害怕吗
Jake: Are you scared? Hmm, are you scared?
其他人：害怕没有那么夸张
Others: Scared? Not that exaggerated.
其他人：那我现在见到真狗可能会
Others: But now if I see a real dog, maybe...
Jake:嗯好吧给他画一个嘴巴
Jake: Hmm, okay, draw a mouth for him.
Jake:他现在他们没有嘴巴所以还好
Jake: They don't have mouths now, so it's fine.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:哼不咬人
Jake: They don't bite.
Jake:还有纹身这些狗
Jake: And these dogs have tattoos.
Jake:这些狗都有
Jake: All these dogs have them.
Jake:对都有纹身
Jake: Yes, they all have tattoos.
Jake:名字呵呵呵呵
Jake: Names, hahaha.
Jake:被纸壳封印了起来
Jake: Sealed with cardboard.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:yes
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 叫床服务已完成
Shure: Wake-up call service is done.
Shure: 想想中午吃什么
Shure: Let's think about what to have for lunch.
Jake:今天该吃什么呢
Jake: What should we eat today?
Jake:咱还有啥没吃着的吗
Jake: Is there anything we haven't eaten yet?
Jake:传统炸东大中华美食
Jake: Traditional fried East China cuisine.
Shure: 传统大中华美食啊
Shure: Traditional Chinese cuisine, huh?
Jake:卤煮
Jake: Lu Zhu.
Shure: 这确确实是传统的
Shure: That really is traditional.
Jake:来一碗吧确实是
Jake: Let's have a bowl, it really is.
Shure: 要能点的话
Shure: If we can order it.
Shure: 我我是很想吃的
Shure: I really want to eat it.
Jake:那就点点个卤煮
Jake: Then let's order Lu Zhu.
Jake:可以多点几个要不每人自己点
Jake: We can order a few more, or everyone can order their own.
Shure: 也行
Shure: That works.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 我的怀里
Shure: In my arms.
Shure: 那里春风沉醉
Shure: The spring breeze is intoxicating there.
Shure: 那绿草如茵
Shure: The green grass is so lush.
Shure: 我们还有两块牛排没煎呢
Shure: We still have two steaks we haven't cooked.
Shure: 要不煎了吧
Shure: How about we cook them?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 这玩意煎好煎赖
Shure: Whether they turn out good or bad,
Shure: 反正他是块肉啊也
Shure: they're still pieces of meat.
Jake:行啊上
Jake: Sure, go ahead.
Shure: 锅刷上就把他俩煎了
Shure: Just brush the pan and cook them.
其他人： ：这还有这个啊好
Others: There's this too, okay.
Shure: 啊好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:血又掉没了是吧
Jake: The blood's all gone again, right?
Jake:要出去打猎
Jake: Need to go out hunting.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Jake:就是又饿
Jake: I'm hungry again.
Jake:不行血又掉没了
Jake: No way, my health dropped again.
Shure: 是的是的
Shure: Yes, yes.
Jake:又得补啊
Jake: I need to replenish it.
Shure: 得补血啊
Shure: You need to replenish your health.
Jake:补血
Jake: Replenish health.
Shure: 那里春风沉醉那里绿草如茵
Shure: The spring breeze is intoxicating there, and the green grass is lush.
Shure: 这是他饱了
Shure: He's full now.
Jake:嗯没有
Jake: Hmm, not really.
Shure: 喂你好
Shure: Hello?
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 爱你
Shure: Love you.
Shure: 拜拜我回家了
Shure: Bye, I'm going home.
Jake:你吃火烧吗
Jake: Do you want to eat "huoshao"?
Shure: 还行都可以
Shure: It's okay, I can eat anything.
Jake:卤煮卧槽
Jake: Braised food, oh my!
Jake:有咱有几个吃卤煮的呀
Jake: How many of us are having braised food?
Jake:吃卤煮吗
Jake: Want some braised food?
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Jake:弄几个大碗
Jake: Get a few big bowls.
Jake:弄几个牛肉火烧
Jake: Get a few beef "huoshao".
Jake:差不多了
Jake: That should be enough.
Jake:嗨1点 嗨1点
Jake: Hi a bit, hi a bit.
Shure: 好啊
Shure: Sure.
Jake:嗨一 点 起床起床去
Jake: Hi a bit, get up, get up.
Shure: 快速关门大家
Shure: Quickly close the door, everyone.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
音乐声：让霓虹呼唤这故事中的摇摆
Music: Let the neon lights call out the swing in this story.
音乐声 ：我的心在
Music: My heart is...
音乐声 ：埋在这人生
Music: Buried in this life.
音乐声：嘟嘟嘟将我心一切就
Music: Doo doo doo, cut my heart all over.
音乐声：一起走过亮起我的舞蹈
Music: Walk together and light up my dance.
音乐声：写上每一段不经意
Music: Write down every unintentional moment.
音乐声 ：怀旧是寻访旧事令我再孤寂
Music: Nostalgia is searching for old stories that make me lonely again.
音乐声 ：还未试过说她清醒
Music: Haven't tried to say she's sober yet.
音乐声：我痴痴爱心花瓣尽过留下
Music: I foolishly love, the flower petals wither and remain.
音乐声 ：如果你只有伤害它深宵里怎将你溶化
Music: If you only hurt, how can you melt it in the deep night.
音乐声：你说爱我吧尚有偏差没你相信吧
Music: You say love me, but there are still deviations, don't you believe it.
音乐声：baby beautiful baby beautiful baby beautiful baby beautiful
Music: Baby beautiful, baby beautiful, baby beautiful, baby beautiful.
音乐声：深秋里的花
Music: Flowers in late autumn
音乐声 ：对象离别地球离别地球仍在唱
Music: Parting from the earth, still singing on earth
音乐声：奉上感情闭上眼睛我都怕
Music: Offering my feelings, closing my eyes, I'm afraid
音乐声：忘掉忧愁忘掉理由忘掉理想的
Music: Forget worries, forget reasons, forget ideals
音乐声：战事最终
Music: The final war
音乐声：变化
Music: Changes
Jake:大伙是醒了
Jake: Everyone's awake
Jake:还是
Jake: Or
Shure: 大伙醒了应该
Shure: Everyone should be awake
Jake:醒了一下是吧
Jake: Awake for a bit, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright
Jake:醒了但是没完全醒
Jake: Awake but not fully awake
Jake:又睡着了啊
Jake: Fell back asleep, huh?
Shure: 没有都醒了
Shure: No, everyone woke up
Jake:接人
Jake: Picking up someone
Shure: 应该是但是稍微洗洗漱一下吧
Shure: Should be, but let's freshen up a bit
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright
音乐声 ：风雪凌霜披身走不羡金刚凭心眸
Music: Facing wind and snow, not envying King Kong, with pure heart
音乐声 ：只为清闲举杯一段感情无悔相逢
Music: Just for leisure, raising a toast, no regrets in meeting
音乐声  ：仗笔天涯寻梦人路人难得几回温
Music: Traveling far with a pen, seeking dreams, rare warmth on the road
音乐声：若有知己共桥上不枉此行度余生
Music: If there is a soulmate on the bridge, this journey is not in vain
音乐声：春风吹吹皱眉百步一摇都是
Music: Spring breeze makes me frown, every hundred steps a sway
音乐声：all my feelings on the way
Music: All my feelings on the way
音乐声：as long as you have no dial tones
Music: As long as you have no dial tones
音乐声：you will get to know the soil of control
Music: You will get to know the soil of control
音乐声：you will get to know
Music: You will get to know
音乐声：all those feelings and my bones gently
Music: All those feelings and my bones gently
Jake:啊拿空挡
Jake: Ah, take the neutral
Shure: I呢抗打
Shure: I can take the hit
Shure: 然后发现一个可以远程访问我电脑
Shure: And then found a way to remotely access my computer
Shure: 直接数据
Shure: Direct data
Shure: 然后直接从那里面拿
Shure: And then directly take it from there
Shure: 我就不用再下一遍那个数据
Shure: So I don't have to download the data again
Shure: 又省去了一大笔时间
Shure: Saved a lot of time
Shure: 他这个真的好慢
Shure: This one is really slow
Shure: 他下载速度只有5啊
Shure: Its download speed is only 5
Shure: 5就是5M你知道吗
Shure: 5 means 5M, you know?
Shure: 就是500KB每秒啊对
Shure: That's 500KB per second, right
Jake:腾讯云放在国内
Jake: Tencent Cloud is based in China
Shure: 然后这3块
Shure: And then these three pieces
Shure: 3块几一个小时
Shure: Three pieces for an hour
Jake:好吧
Jake: Okay
Jake:点了点卤煮
Jake: Ordered some braised pork
Jake:嗯开心吗
Jake: Hmm, are you happy?
Shure: 开心才开心
Shure: Only if you are happy
Shure: 活过来了
Shure: Feeling alive again
Jake:这还有几个牛肉火烧
Jake: There are some beef buns too
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Jake:还行吧还有啥呀
Jake: Not bad, what else is there?
Shure: 还行
Shure: Not bad
Jake:还有啥该吃的没吃着的
Jake: Anything we haven't eaten yet?
Shure: 想想老北京美食还有什么
Shure: Think about what other Beijing delicacies there are
Jake:想一下
Jake: Think about it
Shure: 烤鸭吃过了
Shure: Had roast duck
Jake:吃了整点热干面吧要不呵呵
Jake: How about we have some hot dry noodles, hehe
Jake:呵呵可以整点
Jake: Hehe, we can have some
Shure: 哈哈对
Shure: Haha, yeah
Jake:有没有啊
Jake: Is there any?
Jake:北京应该有但不知道外送查查看
Jake: Should be in Beijing, but not sure about delivery, let's check
Shure: 你让武汉人评价一下
Shure: Ask a Wuhan person to review it
Jake:热干面咋样啊好吃
Jake: How's the hot dry noodles, tasty?
其他人：麦当劳汉堡哦
Others: McDonald's burger, oh
Jake:晚上吃麦当劳汉堡
Jake: Having McDonald's burger tonight
其他人 ：晚上吗晚上晚上可以吗
Others: Tonight? Tonight, is that okay?
其他人：可以中午
Others: We can do lunch
Jake:中午吃卤煮
Jake: Lunch with braised pork
Jake:驴肉火烧
Jake: Donkey meat bun
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 你要不点点点
Shure: How about you order
Alice: ：吃卤煮啊
Alice: Eating braised pork?
Jake:不吃卤煮
Jake: Not eating braised pork
Shure: 点那个在清清小清新一点的东西
Shure: Order something a bit lighter
Jake:那几家店没有小清新的东西
Jake: Those places don't have lighter options
Jake:那火烧火烧吃吗
Jake: So, donkey meat buns?
Shure: 驴肉火上
Shure: Donkey meat buns
Jake:驴肉火烧
Jake: Donkey meat buns
Jake:牛肉火烧呢
Jake: How about beef buns?
Shure: 尝尝你就知道了
Shure: Try it and you'll know
Jake:就是饼就是饼
Jake: It's just bread, just bread
Jake:点几个煎饼吧
Jake: Let's order some pancakes.
Jake:要不就山东煎饼天津煎饼
Jake: How about Shandong pancakes or Tianjin pancakes?
Alice:需要一个擦眼镜布
Alice: We need a cloth to clean the glasses.
Alice: ：这个眼镜
Alice: These glasses.
Alice:这个还有面包
Alice: And also some bread.
Jake:好我给你下面
Jake: Okay, I'll bring it down for you.
Jake:我给你拿上来或者你下去好嘞
Jake: I'll bring it up for you or you can come down. Got it.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:你有擦眼镜的布吗
Jake: Do you have a cloth for cleaning glasses?
Jake:在一个我放到了一个盒子里
Jake: I put it in a box.
Jake:不知道是谁的盒子
Jake: Not sure whose box it is.
Jake:不是你的核心是你的吗
Jake: It's not yours, is it?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake:你的盒我能看一下吗
Jake: Can I check your box?
Alice:我的盒呢
Alice: Where's my box?
Alice:我找一下在哪
Alice: I'll look for it.
Jake:哎你的盒
Jake: Hey, your box.
Jake:好吧你的盒在这
Jake: Okay, your box is here.
Alice: ：我的盒在楼上但是它里面没有
Alice: My box is upstairs, but it's not in there.
Jake:那不应该呀
Jake: That shouldn't be.
Jake:稍等啊把这丢了先
Jake: Hold on, let me throw this away first.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn.
Alice:哈
Alice: Huh.
其他人 ：真的吗真的真的我
Others: Really? Really, really.
其他人：妈呀
Others: Oh my god.
Shure: 听过先唱第二天就发烧
Shure: Heard about singing first and then getting a fever the next day.
Alice:哈
Alice: Huh.
Shure: 他踩井盖
Shure: He stepped on a manhole cover.
Shure: 这个是文化差异的属于
Shure: This is a cultural difference.
Alice:哈
Alice: Huh.
Jake:这个刚刚
Jake: This just happened.
Jake:嗯嗯这个这个
Jake: Yeah, yeah, this, this.
Jake:在地上捡着但是不一定干净哦试试
Jake: I picked it up from the ground, but it may not be clean. Give it a try.
Alice: ：但是您不是洗过了吗
Alice: But didn't you wash it?
Jake:对我先把这这样擦一下
Jake: Yes, let me wipe it like this first.
Alice: ：然后再拿个餐巾纸
Alice: Then use a napkin.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:不过一般来说根据我戴眼镜的经验
Alice: But generally speaking, from my experience wearing glasses...
Jake:餐巾纸擦不干净对
Jake: A napkin won't clean it properly.
Jake:会带电
Jake: It'll carry a charge.
Alice:会不会磨到这个镜片啊
Alice: Will it scratch the lens?
Alice: ：如果用餐巾纸的话
Alice: If I use a napkin?
Jake:没关系这镜片不值钱
Jake: It's okay, the lens isn't valuable.
Jake:哈哈哈镜片眼镜值镜片
Jake: Hahaha, the glasses are worth more than the lens.
Alice:这是可以说的吗
Alice: Can you say that?
Jake:不值钱镜片
Jake: The lens isn't worth much.
Jake:对镜框值钱镜片
Jake: Yeah, the frame is valuable, not the lens.
Jake:咱要不把镜片摘了吧
Jake: Should we just remove the lens?
Jake:咱这这没度数
Jake: There's no prescription in these.
其他人 ：哦这镜片能摘吗
Others: Oh, can the lens be removed?
Alice:可以摘吗
Alice: Can it be removed?
Jake:能摘吗呃
Jake: Can it be removed, uh...
Alice:录一个去镜片的活动
Alice: Record an activity of removing the lens.
Jake:对好摘
Jake: Yeah, it's easy to remove.
Jake:但是不好摘对
Jake: But not that easy, yeah.
Jake:能摘但是不好摘对
Jake: It can be removed, but it's not easy, yeah.
Jake:对算了
Jake: Yeah, forget it.
Jake:咱就哎对
Jake: Let's just, yeah.
Jake:还有一个就是我们
Jake: Another thing is, we...
Jake:就是你昨天挂掉的
Jake: Like you hung up yesterday.
Jake:原因是你可能一不小心碰到了这个
Jake: The reason is you might have accidentally touched this.
Alice:哦对这个是什么
Alice: Oh right, what is this?
Jake:对就是这个
Jake: Yeah, it's this.
Jake:是这个是允许拍摄
Jake: This allows filming.
Jake:这是不允许拍摄
Jake: This doesn't allow filming.
Jake:就是你现在如果
Jake: So now if you...
Jake:就比方说是你如果后悔了
Jake: For example, if you regret it.
Jake:这一段你不想拍
Jake: You don't want to film this part.
Alice: 快捷键的
Alice: Shortcut key.
Jake:然后你就咔之前全部删掉了
Jake: Then you just delete everything before this.
Jake:对快捷键的对
Jake: Yeah, the shortcut key, yeah.
Jake:一键删除
Jake: One-click delete.
Alice: ：一键删除
Alice: One-click delete.
Jake:嗯昨天就一键删除了
Jake: Yeah, yesterday it was all deleted with one click.
Jake:呵呵呵就是没有拍到你被狗咬
Jake: Haha, so it didn't capture you being bitten by the dog.
Jake:他没有拍到你被狗咬的这个镜头
Jake: It didn't capture the footage of you being bitten by the dog.
Alice:呀
Alice: Ah.
Jake:嗯没删到
Jake: Yeah, it wasn't deleted.
Alice: ：我应该拍到你
Alice: I should have filmed you.
Jake:你自己拍到了
Jake: You filmed it yourself.
Jake:你没有一键删除
Jake: You don't have a one-click delete.
Jake:好打成功
Jake: Alright, success.
Jake:好的好
Jake: Okay, good.
Alice:我觉今天下午我们应该要布置了
Alice: I think we should start decorating this afternoon.
其他人：昨天 的还没删呢
Others: Yesterday's stuff isn't deleted yet.
其他人 ：还在上面
Others: It's still up there.
其他人：对不起
Others: Sorry.
Jake: 反应了一会
Jake: Took a while to respond.
Jake:呵呵话音未落
Jake: Haha, before I could finish speaking.
Jake:他自己就删掉了
Jake: He deleted it himself.
Jake:难道你也开了一键删除
Jake: Did you also enable one-click delete?
Jake:哈哈没有没有
Jake: Haha, no, no.
Jake:你删了你们都删了
Jake: You deleted it, all of you deleted it.
Jake:我们要做几条狗啊
Jake: How many dogs do we need to make?
其他人：我已经做完了我的狗
Others: I've already finished my dog.
其他人 ：我们每人做一条狗
Others: Each of us makes one dog.
Jake:放在门口
Jake: Place it at the door.
Alice:  ：要给它起个名字好嘞
Alice: We need to give it a name, sure.
Alice:我的叫
Alice: I'll name mine.
Alice:乐乐吧比较快乐的样子
Alice: Lele, it sounds happy.
Alice:有人的小名叫乐乐吗哈哈哈
Alice: Does anyone have a nickname Lele? Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:暂时还没有
Jake: Not yet.
Alice:但其实他还没有完全完成
Alice: But actually, it's not completely finished.
Jake:还差点啥
Jake: What's still missing?
Alice:因为剪这个实在是太费手了
Alice: Cutting this is really hard on the hands.
Alice:你没看见他这个是一整条
Alice: Didn't you see, this is a whole piece.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:他这个火车
Jake: This train.
Jake:小狗火车
Jake: Little dog train.
Alice:火车狗
Alice: Train dog.
Alice:我想给我的狗别个大花
Alice: I want to put a big flower on my dog.
Jake:模范狗
Jake: Model dog.
Alice:他扭个花戴上
Alice: Twist a flower and put it on.
Jake:狗
Jake: Dog.
Alice:我也有一个明天到
Alice: I have one arriving tomorrow too.
Alice:然后我那个挂布到了
Alice: And my hanging cloth arrived.
Alice:但是我正在想办法把它挂起来
Alice: But I'm figuring out how to hang it.
Alice:我觉得不太好挂
Alice: I think it's not easy to hang.
Lucia: 做出了水母灯他也亮不了
Lucia: Made a jellyfish lamp but it doesn't light up.
Shure: 啊啊啊
Shure: Ah ah ah
Lucia: 但我们可以认为他是一个水母
Lucia: But we can consider it as a jellyfish.
Lucia: 没有灯
Lucia: No light.
Lucia: 去掉灯字
Lucia: Remove the word "light."
Jake:咱就拿手电筒照一照
Jake: Let's just shine a flashlight on it.
Lucia: 也可以理论上说
Lucia: You could say theoretically.
Jake:就理论上说
Jake: Theoretically speaking.
Lucia: 比如说像这样
Lucia: For example, like this.
Jake:给个特效
Jake: Add some special effects.
Lucia: 我觉得这个瓶子还行
Lucia: I think this bottle is okay.
Lucia: 他这要是弧度更
Lucia: If this curvature were more...
Lucia: 就是slope更陡一点就好了
Lucia: If the slope were steeper, it would be better.
Jake:嗯自动更远一点就好了
Jake: Hmm, if it were automatic and a bit further, it would be better.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake:OK那你把它放就
Jake: OK, then you put it...
Alice:你把它放起来吧
Alice: You put it away.
Lucia: 就
Lucia: So...
Lucia: 本来应该在这里面放一个那种小灯珠
Lucia: Originally, we should put a small bulb inside here.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:那是得像那种哎
Jake: It should be like that, um...
Jake:那叫啥呢
Jake: What do you call it?
Jake:苏打水或者可
Jake: Soda water or something...
Jake:可以买其实就是很品的那种
Jake: You can buy, actually, it's just that kind...
Jake:是果汁那种
Jake: It's the juice kind.
Lucia: 就是圆一点的就
Lucia: Just a rounder one...
Jake:就是圆可乐吗
Jake: Like a round Coke bottle?
Lucia: 呃怎么说呢
Lucia: Uh, how to say...
Lucia: 就是网上那种
Lucia: Like those online...
Lucia: 就是废物利用的那种教程
Lucia: Those DIY tutorials for recycling.
Lucia: 他用的是那种奶茶盖的可乐瓶
Lucia: They use those milk tea bottle caps for Coke bottles.
Alice:可乐瓶隔瓶这个应该还行
Alice: A Coke bottle, this might work.
Alice:原我觉得原森林那个葫芦就还不错
Alice: I think the original forest gourd was pretty good.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 就是就是
Lucia: Just, just...
Lucia: 我们如果用小瓶子做的话
Lucia: If we use a small bottle...
Lucia: 它就会比较小
Lucia: It'll be relatively small.
Lucia: 元气森林
Lucia: Yuanqi Forest.
Lucia: 我觉得这就还可以剪到这个位置
Lucia: I think we can cut it to this position.
Alice:我决定给我的狗做几个
Alice: I decided to make a few for my dog.
Jake:早上好戴眼镜了吗
Jake: Good morning, are you wearing glasses?
Alice:哈哈哈就是这样
Alice: Hahaha, that's how it is.
Jake:那就戴一下呗
Jake: Then just wear it.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no.
Shure: 叫什么你知道ADHD这个这个病吗
Shure: Do you know about ADHD, this condition?
Shure: 叫什么
Shure: What's it called?
Jake:ADHD
Jake: ADHD.
Shure: 注意力缺陷什么的那种
Shure: Attention deficit something like that.
Jake:哦嗯
Jake: Oh, yeah.
Shure: 就是像我现在这个样子
Shure: It's like how I am now.
Shure: 拿到什么东西就开始甩
Shure: I just start shaking whatever I get.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈我也可以作为那个病例参考的
Shure: Haha, I could be a case study for it.
Shure: 珍贵影像
Shure: Rare footage.
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Jake:呵啊
Jake: Hah, yeah.
Jake:怎么了
Jake: What's wrong?
Jake:打不开
Jake: It won't open.
Jake:插个电就打开了
Jake: Just plug it in and it'll open.
Alice:啊啊
Alice: Ahhh.
Jake:插电即开即插
Jake: Plug in and it opens.
Jake:因为这是我的充电宝
Jake: Because this is my power bank.
Jake:你先开了
Jake: You turn it on first.
Jake:你开了可以再领一个充电宝对
Jake: Once you turn it on, you can get another power bank, right?
Jake:对对对对就是这样
Jake: Yeah, yeah, that's it.
Jake:呃点了
Jake: Uh, clicked it.
Jake:可能再过10分钟吧
Jake: Maybe in about 10 minutes.
Jake:就有牛肉火烧吃了
Jake: There'll be beef buns ready.
Jake:牛肉火烧
Jake: Beef buns.
Jake:我怎么我没怎么吃过
Jake: I haven't eaten them much.
Jake:你吃的多吗
Jake: Do you eat them a lot?
Shure: 我吃也不多
Shure: Not much either.
Jake:嗯那挺好还行
Jake: Hmm, that's good, still okay.
Jake:你昨天都是0418
Jake: Yesterday it was all 0418.
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Shure: 不行看时间戳
Shure: No, look at the timestamp.
Shure: 改一下吧杨老板
Shure: Change it, Jake.
Jake:嗯好说
Jake: Hmm, sure.
Jake:这个好说
Jake: That's doable.
Tasha: 哎呦好脏呀
Tasha: Oh, it's so dirty.
Tasha: 眼睛布呢
Tasha: Where's the blindfold?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟
Shure: Doo doo doo doo doo
音乐声：看到我所有的解脱
Music: See all my release
Shure: na
音乐声：不希望不容易
Music: It's not easy to have no hope
Shure: na
音乐声：有绝望不害怕
Music: There's despair but no fear
音乐声：不希望不需要一朵花
Music: No hope, no need for a flower
Shure: na na
音乐声：告诉我我们的一切如果
Music: Tell me everything if
音乐声：还有那一刹那的发酵
Music: And that moment of fermentation
Jake:i'm i音乐声with your
Jake: I'm... I'm music with your...
音乐声 ：body
Music: body
音乐声：光明请给我一个梦
Music: Light, please give me a dream
音乐声：我不怕风雨
Music: I'm not afraid of the wind and rain
音乐声 ：你的笑脸
Music: Your smile
音乐声：偷走心碎的
Music: Stole the heartbreak
音乐声：盘旋在我手心里
Music: Swirling in my palm
音乐声：你给的啊
Music: What you gave, ah
小薇音乐声
Tasha: (music playing)
Jake:呀你昨天全给你的
Jake: Hey, did you give everything to him yesterday?
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 因为你说这样就不用发我的工资了
Tasha: Because you said I wouldn't need to get my salary then.
Jake:哦确实
Jake: Oh, right.
Tasha: 你不就是这个意思吗
Tasha: Isn't that what you meant?
Jake:是这个意思人挺好
Jake: Yeah, that's what I meant. You're pretty good.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
音乐声：太阳把大海照亮抵挡在波浪上
Music: The sun illuminates the sea, held back by the waves
音乐声：海鸟盘旋在梦境中央奔跑在肩上
Music: Seagulls circle in the middle of the dream, running on shoulders
音乐声：现在我还希望
Music: Now I still hope
Jake:开了吗
Jake: Is it on?
音乐声 ：我要我一直坚持你的倔强
Music: I want to keep sticking to your stubbornness
Jake:开了
Jake: It's on.
Jake:雨轩开了吗好嘞
Jake: Yuxuan, is it on? Alright.
音乐声：在每次飘落的日子
Music: On every drifting day
Jake:咱今整点啥
Jake: What should we do today?
Tasha: 整点啥
Tasha: What should we do?
Tasha: 做啥都可以
Tasha: We can do anything.
Jake:要做多少
Jake: How much should we do?
Jake:要做多少东西
Jake: How much do we need to make?
Tasha: 做多少都可以
Tasha: As much as you want.
Jake:做多少都可以
Jake: As much as you want.
Tasha: 现在开始做也可以
Tasha: We can start making it now too.
Jake:那得做呀
Jake: Yeah, we need to make it.
Jake:还挺多的吧
Jake: There's quite a lot, right?
Tasha: 对做做
Tasha: Yes, let's do it.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 你想吃什么
Tasha: What do you want to eat?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:还有啥没做的吗
Jake: Is there anything we haven't made yet?
Tasha: 芋头芋头吃不了了
Tasha: The taro, we can't eat it anymore.
Jake:芋头
Jake: Taro.
Tasha: 芋头到不了了
Tasha: The taro didn't arrive.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 请塔莎老师
Shure: Please ask Tasha.
Jake:为啥呀
Jake: Why?
Tasha: 怎么了哦
Tasha: What's wrong?
Tasha: 怎么是热的
Tasha: Why is it hot?
Jake:放点冰块
Jake: Add some ice cubes.
Jake:呵呵咱冰块
Jake: Haha, our ice cubes.
Jake:是说要买是吗
Jake: Do we need to buy them?
Shure: 冰块有
Shure: We have ice cubes.
Jake:冰块有有啊
Jake: We have ice cubes?
Jake:是吗哪呢
Jake: Really? Where?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Tasha: 哪呢
Tasha: Where?
Shure: 在楼下的那个
Shure: In the freezer downstairs.
Jake:好买了是吧
Jake: Okay, you bought them, right?
Tasha: 哦冰格里是吗
Tasha: Oh, in the ice tray?
Shure: 不是就是上次想起来没对
Shure: No, we just remembered it last time.
Katrina: 你美团送
Katrina: You got it delivered by Meituan.
Katrina: 送的那一坨
Katrina: That big chunk.
Shure: 凑单然后我凑了一袋瓶
Shure: Yeah, I added a bag to make the order.
Tasha: 你要吗
Tasha: Do you need it?
Shure: 你用吗我不用
Shure: Do you need it? I don't.
Shure: 你先用吧
Shure: You use it first.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:好加冰
Jake: Okay, add ice.
Shure: 你洗你葡萄
Shure: You wash your grapes.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure: 我冲我的咖啡
Shure: I'll make my coffee.
Tasha: 不能喝冰
Tasha: You can't drink ice.
Jake:不要
Jake: No.
Jake:你你又不是直接吃冰
Jake: You're not eating ice directly.
Shure: 这可以丢掉
Shure: This can be thrown away.
Shure: 其实你先给他放那放那吧
Shure: Actually, put it there first.
Shure: 先一会丢了
Shure: Throw it away later.
Shure: 记得我们有这个有这个
Shure: Remember we have this.
Shure: 要丢的东西
Shure: Stuff to throw away.
Shure: 怎么不满了
Shure: Why isn't it full?
Shure: 站你旁边碍你眼了是吗
Shure: Am I blocking your view?
Katrina: 哈哈我要摔碟子骂人了
Katrina: Haha, I'm going to break dishes and curse.
Katrina: 太阳好好啊
Katrina: The sun is so nice.
Katrina: 又要洗衣服
Katrina: Time to do laundry again.
Shure: 要骂厨子了是吗
Shure: Going to curse the cook?
Katrina: 还养的多吗
Katrina: Are there still many left?
Shure: 走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina: 之前看人家说亲戚家养乐多
Katrina: I saw someone saying their relative has a lot.
Katrina: 捣捣捣捣把它捣碎那种很爽
Katrina: Crushing it feels really good.
Katrina: 那这个要留着明天
Katrina: Keep this for tomorrow.
Shure: 对可以直接点盒马外送的其实
Shure: Yeah, you can just order delivery from Hema.
Shure: 这个逼搞不起来啊
Shure: This thing won't work.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure: 一直发网络问题
Shure: Keeps having network issues.
Jake:啥给强了呀
Jake: What's being forced?
Jake:唉不行啊
Jake: Oh no, it's not working.
Jake:为了十年之后的10个亿
Jake: For the 1 billion in 10 years.
Alice:你怎么了微微
Alice: What's wrong, Tasha?
Jake:怎么了
Jake: What's wrong?
Jake:必须搞必须搞必须搞
Jake: We have to do it, we have to do it.
Jake:今天必须搞
Jake: We have to do it today.
Lucia: 10个小目标
Lucia: 10 small goals.
Tasha: 他楼上冲的黑咖啡
Tasha: He's making black coffee upstairs.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 发起150个
Shure: Sent out 150.
Shure: 我自己偷偷雪藏50个
Shure: I secretly held back 50.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Alice:咖啡可以苦不能酸
Alice: Coffee can be bitter but not sour.
Lucia: 我头好疼啊
Lucia: My head really hurts.
Lucia: 啊没事
Lucia: Ah, it's nothing.
Jake:打针的
Jake: Because of the injection?
Lucia: 可能是打针的问题
Lucia: Maybe it's because of the injection.
Jake:来怎么看看怎么准
Jake: Let's see how accurate it is.
Shure: 那就等这个砖好
Shure: Let's wait for the brick to set.
Shure: 砖不好
Shure: The brick isn't good.
Jake:花多少钱啊
Jake: How much does it cost?
Shure: 这个他这应该砖好
Shure: It should be good now.
Shure: 要花一点点小费用哦
Shure: It'll cost a little bit.
Jake:他这有墙吗
Jake: Does he have a wall?
Jake:你这有墙吗
Jake: Do you have a wall?
Jake:你这番吗
Jake: Do you have a fan?
Jake:你这global
Jake: Are you global?
Shure: 不懂啊
Shure: I don't understand.
Jake:你是global吗
Jake: Are you global?
Shure: 是global哦
Shure: Yes, I'm global.
Shure: 我是这个
Shure: I am this.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Jake:哎。
Jake: Hey.
Tasha: 我们今天要再采购一次
Tasha: We need to shop again today.
Tasha: 然后再做甜品
Tasha: Then make some desserts.
Tasha: 牛奶也没了
Tasha: We're out of milk too.
Jake:那就买呗
Jake: Then buy some.
Tasha: 那是去超市还是直接手机上买
Tasha: Should we go to the supermarket or buy it online?
Jake:我想想啊
Jake: Let me think.
Jake:一会问一下大家有没有别的要买的
Jake: I'll ask everyone if they need anything else.
Jake:或者比方说你没到的东西
Jake: Or if there's something you didn't get.
Jake:如果多的话直接出去买
Jake: If there's a lot, we'll go out and buy it.
Jake:好呀去超市买VR
Jake: Okay, let's go to the supermarket and buy VR.
Jake:还有什么没到的东西吗
Jake: Is there anything else we haven't gotten?
Tasha: 我的欧根纱和一个就是镭射海光纸
Tasha: My organza and a laser holographic paper.
Jake:那东西能买到吗
Jake: Can we buy those things?
Tasha: 不知道哈哈
Tasha: I don't know, haha.
Tasha: 我们可以在外面多逛逛
Tasha: We can look around outside.
Tasha: 然后看看如果如果时间允许
Tasha: Then see if we have enough time.
Jake:这可以商量商量时间
Jake: We can discuss the time.
Jake:看看时间不多了
Jake: Looks like there's not much time left.
Tasha: 明天明天活动的话
Tasha: About tomorrow's event...
Tasha: 我们是不是得把这俩客厅收拾收拾
Tasha: Should we tidy up the living rooms?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 见不得人哈
Tasha: It's quite a mess, huh?
Lucia: 哈哈哈我们这个客厅现在状态
Lucia: Haha, our living room is in such a state.
Lucia: 会不会过于真实了
Lucia: Isn't it a bit too real?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:我们压花怎么说
Jake: So, what about our pressed flowers?
Jake:我们压花现在是什么
Jake: What's the status of our pressed flowers?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Katrina: 压完了压完了哦
Katrina: They're done, they're done.
Jake:Panda压完了是吗
Jake: Panda, are they all done?
Lucia: 昨天的压花可以取了吗
Lucia: Can we take the pressed flowers from yesterday?
Katrina: 里面有蜜蜂哎
Katrina: There's a bee inside.
Lucia: 哎没有我刚打开的
Lucia: Oh no, I just opened it.
Katrina: 我们去把它晒一会太阳应该
Katrina: We should let it sit in the sun for a bit.
Lucia: 可以好的
Lucia: Alright.
Katrina: 但是昨天下午才压应该还不够
Katrina: But we only pressed them yesterday afternoon, so it might not be enough.
Lucia: 我刚才就是把它打开
Lucia: I just opened it,
Lucia: 之后在想能不能就是整个拆开
Lucia: and was thinking about taking it all apart.
Lucia: 但我又不敢
Lucia: But I was too scared.
Lucia: 所以我又没拆
Lucia: So I didn't.
Jake:OK那这些花是放回卧室是吗还是搁这
Jake: Okay, so should we put these flowers back in the bedroom or leave them here?
Katrina: 可以放回卧室
Katrina: We can put them back in the bedroom.
Lucia: 可以放回卧室吧
Lucia: Yeah, let's put them back in the bedroom.
Jake:那就放回卧室吧
Jake: Alright, let's do that.
Katrina: 今天等一会下午看一下有没有压
Katrina: Let's check this afternoon to see if they're pressed enough.
Katrina: 好的有的
Katrina: Sure thing.
Katrina: 那个花瓣可能就好了
Katrina: The petals might be ready.
Katrina: 就可以自己做
Katrina: Then we can make our own.
Katrina: 就明信片
Katrina: Like postcards.
Jake:那我们先把这个花给放回去吧
Jake: Okay, let's put these flowers back first.
Jake:让客厅看起来东西少一点
Jake: To make the living room look less cluttered.
Jake:自个卧室
Jake: Each one to their bedroom.
Lucia: 这好像是我的
Lucia: I think this one is mine.
Lucia: 我想给他换换水可以换吗
Lucia: I want to change the water, is that okay?
Lucia: 换了他不会他不会他不会嘎吧
Lucia: It won't, it won't wither, right?
Katrina: 噔噔噔噔噔
Katrina: *humming*
Alice:他是自然的老去
Alice: It'll just age naturally.
Lucia: 那我到洗手间去换啊
Lucia: I'll go change it in the bathroom then.
Lucia: 您在切芒果
Lucia: You're cutting a mango.
Jake:呀
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 让我们看看今天的转化率有多少
Lucia: Let's see what the conversion rate is today.
Jake:好称一下
Jake: Okay, let's weigh it.
Lucia: 啊在这
Lucia: Ah, here it is.
Jake:呵呵好嘞
Jake: Hehe, alright.
Lucia: 我看看
Lucia: Let me see.
Shure: 那个拿一个包躲在我这屋干什么呢
Shure: Why are you hiding with a bag in my room?
Lucia: 给您清好零了
Shure: 这什么
Shure: What's this?
Lucia: 你可以先把盘子放在上面
Lucia: You can put the plate on it first.
Lucia: 然后清一下铃
Lucia: Then clear the bell.
Lucia: 然后再称它
Lucia: Then weigh it again.
Lucia: 就是要把这些拿起来
Lucia: You have to take these off first.
Lucia: 我已经学会了
Lucia: I've learned it.
Lucia: 薇薇如何使用这个秤
Lucia: Tasha taught me how to use this scale.
Lucia: 就是好像有点有点不平
Lucia: It seems a bit uneven.
Tasha: 怎么安装它呢
Tasha: How do you set it up?
Lucia: 我们还是在这里吧
Lucia: Let's stay here.
Jake:对就在这就在这行
Jake: Yeah, right here is fine.
Lucia: 就是您可以先把这个盘子放上来
Lucia: You can put this plate on first.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 然后把芒果拿走
Lucia: Then take the mango off.
Lucia: 哇这盘子这么重
Lucia: Wow, this plate is so heavy.
Jake:哎我好像有快递
Jake: Oh, I think I have a delivery.
Lucia: 青柠嗯好
Lucia: Lime? Okay.
Lucia: 然后哎您又碰到了
Lucia: Oh, you touched it again.
Jake:我有快递到了
Jake: I have a delivery.
Lucia: 嗯又有快递到了
Lucia: Hmm, another delivery.
Jake:呃应该是外卖驴肉火烧
Jake: It should be donkey meat sandwiches.
Jake:没吃过卤煮
Jake: Never had braised pork.
Lucia: 没有真没有
Lucia: No, really haven't.
Jake:好嘞哎你好
Jake: Alright, hello.
其他人 ：哎你好外卖到了
Others: Hello, your delivery is here.
Jake:哎好来了来了来了来了来了
Jake: Hey, okay, coming, coming, coming.
Jake:你在哪啊
Jake: Where are you?
其他人 ：在门在门口
Others: At the door.
其他人：这个我看到有个53号啊好
Others: I see number 53, right?
Jake:呃这别别别动啊53号
Jake: Uh, don't move, number 53.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh.
Jake:然后您可能得
Jake: Then you might have to...
Jake:哎我靠你在哪啊我我们是31号 就是
Jake: Hey, damn it, where are you? We're at number 31, just...
其他人 ：031号得往里边走是吧
Others: Number 31 is further inside, right?
Jake:对对对看到没
Jake: Yeah, yeah, did you see it?
Jake:哎你看到我了
Jake: Hey, you saw me.
Jake:哎呀完了
Jake: Oh no, it's over.
其他人 ：少了一点摊出来
Others: It's a bit short, spread it out more.
Jake:好的这是卤煮
Jake: Okay, this is braised pork.
Jake:卤煮烫杀
Jake: Braised pork, hot and fresh.
Jake:真他妈
Jake: Damn it.
其他人 ：他这个包装他在保上面这边没盖住
Others: The packaging didn't cover the top properly.
Jake:哎呦好嘞
Jake: Oh, got it.
其他人：看要不我赔
Others: How about I compensate you?
其他人：赔你点钱你看行吗
Others: Let me pay you some money, is that okay?
Jake:行吧这也哎我靠
Jake: Alright, fine, damn it.
Jake:好好好没事没事没事没事爱爱咋咋地
Jake: Alright, alright, it's fine, it's fine, whatever.
Jake:行谢谢你啊
Jake: Okay, thanks.
Jake:没事没事
Jake: It's okay.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:不行啊可疑了
Jake: No, this is suspicious.
Shure: 那里春风沉醉
Shure: The spring breeze is intoxicating there.
Jake:来负责一下
Jake: Come and take charge.
Jake:分一分
Jake: Distribute it.
Jake:这个他路上撒了卤煮
Jake: He spilled the braised pork on the way.
Jake:撒了很可以撒了很
Jake: Spilled a lot, really a lot.
Jake:卤煮越来越越看越想吃了
Jake: The more I look at the braised pork, the more I want to eat it.
Jake:是
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 这其实他是一种冒菜吗是
Shure: Actually, is this a type of spicy hot pot?
Lucia: 所以它是一种冒菜吗
Lucia: So, is this a type of spicy hot pot?
Shure: no no no这卤煮闻着下水味就有点重
Shure: No, no, no, the smell of the braised pork is pretty strong.
Jake:是
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:下水味重是吧
Jake: The smell is strong, right?
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Lucia: 什么它里面是下水吗
Lucia: What, is there offal in it?
Lucia: 不是它是用下水做的吗
Lucia: No, is it made with offal?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:就是硬煮
Jake: It's just hard-boiled.
Lucia: 硬煮
Lucia: Hard-boiled?
Jake:就是煮啊
Jake: Yeah, just boiled.
Jake:煮煮煮直接煮
Jake: Boil, boil, just boil it directly.
Shure: 这其实
Shure: This actually...
Shure: 分两个人分吃吧
Shure: Let's split it between two people.
Shure: 或者三个人
Shure: Or three people.
Shure: 或者自己每个人拿个小碗接着吃吧
Shure: Or we can each take a small bowl and keep eating.
Jake:拿小碗接着吃
Jake: Take a small bowl and keep eating.
Shure: 拿小碗接着吃
Shure: Take a small bowl and keep eating.
Shure: 对行
Shure: Yeah, right.
Jake:对你多整点小碗嘛
Jake: Right, get more small bowls.
Jake:我找不着碗了
Jake: I can't find the bowls.
Shure: 行那去楼下吃楼上吃
Shure: Fine, then let's eat downstairs or upstairs.
Lucia: 我看一下楼下的桌子现在情况怎么样
Lucia: I'll check how the table downstairs looks.
Lucia: 应该大家都把
Lucia: Everyone should have...
Jake:很不怎么样呃哈哈哈哈
Jake: Not great, haha.
Lucia: 呃不是大家都把花搬走了吗
Lucia: Didn't everyone move the flowers?
Jake:哦这样啊
Jake: Oh, I see.
Shure: 然后把那个电脑收一下
Shure: And tidy up the computer.
Shure: 我的室友们给点力呀
Shure: Come on, roommates, help out a bit.
Lucia: 还有一瓶
Lucia: There's one more bottle.
Jake:好我开始切了
Jake: Alright, I'll start cutting.
Lucia: 这好像是您的吧
Lucia: This seems to be yours.
Jake:我不是我的哎
Jake: Nope, it isn't mine.
Lucia: 哦不是是修硕的
Lucia: Oh, it's Shure's.
Jake:给他放过去
Jake: Give it to him then.
Lucia: 哦对我还没有称这个
Lucia: Oh, right, I haven't weighed this yet.
Lucia: 咦这芒果好热呀
Lucia: Wow, this mango is so warm.
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Jake:把这个给修硕窗台
Jake: Put this on Shure's windowsill.
Lucia: 这芒果有85.8克
Lucia: This mango weighs 85.8 grams.
Jake:这么重哎呦
Jake: That heavy? Oh my.
Tasha: 你要开始转换率了吗
Tasha: Are you going to start the conversion rate?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Alice:干嘛呀
Alice: What for?
Lucia: 不是是杨老板要开始转化他了
Lucia: No, Jake is going to start converting it.
Tasha: 吃饭吗
Tasha: For eating?
Jake:我要转化他吃
Jake: I'm going to convert it for eating.
Jake:吃卤煮
Jake: For stew.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: What?
Jake:上楼吃卤煮
Jake: Let's go upstairs to eat stew.
Tasha: 你骗我
Tasha: You're kidding me.
Jake:啊还有火烧
Jake: Ah, there's still some buns.
Jake:火烧有奶了
Jake: The buns have milk now.
Jake:我还得出去一趟
Jake: I need to go out for a bit.
Lucia: 没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Jake:哎你好
Jake: Hey, hello.
Lucia: 我们那天那个啥做甜点的说闹着玩了
Lucia: That day, the person making desserts was just joking around.
Lucia: 就是说看那一个芒果能削出多少来
Lucia: They were saying how much they could peel from a mango.
Jake:喂
Jake: Hello?
Jake:这这里边里边31您看31在哪
Jake: This, inside here, 31. Can you see where 31 is?
Jake:哎好
Jake: Ah, okay.
其他人 ：你看你这写53
Others: Look, you wrote 53.
Jake:对怕31找不着就31难找
Jake: Yes, I was afraid 31 would be hard to find. It's hard to find 31.
Jake:谢谢谢谢
Jake: Thank you, thank you.
Lucia: 我需要一个充电宝
Lucia: I need a power bank.
Jake:没有了是吧
Jake: There isn't any, right?
Tasha: what's this煎饼果子
Tasha: What's this? Jianbing guozi.
Lucia: 没 看到那个太大了
Lucia: No, that one was too big.
Lucia: 我这裙子没有口袋
Lucia: My dress doesn't have pockets.
Alice:火烧
Alice: Buns.
Shure: two
Shure: Two.
Jake:这个这个可能还行
Jake: This one might work.
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What's this?
Lucia: 这是充电宝啊
Lucia: This is a power bank.
Jake:对你可以试试
Jake: Yeah, you can try it.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:你插上之后过一会看看他正在充电
Jake: After you plug it in, see if it's charging.
Lucia: 试试看我好像把线放在这
Lucia: Let me try, I think I left the cable here.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 是我吗是我的good
Lucia: Is it me? Is it mine? Good.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:行
Jake: Okay.
Jake:我我要转化
Jake: I need to convert.
Jake:帮我提谢谢
Jake: Help me lift it, thanks.
Jake:我转化一下
Jake: I'll convert it.
Jake:哎这个不测转化率呢
Jake: Hey, isn't this for testing conversion rates?
Lucia: 测好了嗯
Lucia: It's tested, hmm.
Jake:测好了测好了
Jake: It's tested, it's tested.
Lucia: 他一个反正刚才的那个是89克
Lucia: The one just now was 89 grams.
Jake:嗯哦哦让我
Jake: Hmm, oh, let me...
Jake:在这操作是吧
Jake: Operate here, right?
Lucia: 相当于这个
Lucia: Equivalent to this
Lucia: 我看有没有电啊
Lucia: Let me see if it has power
Lucia: 太亮起了两道杠
Lucia: It's really bright, there are two bars
Lucia: 什么意思
Lucia: What does that mean?
Jake:呃就是他他开了
Jake: Uh, it means it's on
Lucia: 那他不显示电量吗
Lucia: Doesn't it show the battery level?
Jake:他没有电量显示
Jake: It doesn't have a battery indicator
Jake:他这个设计
Jake: This design
Lucia: 好落后哦
Lucia: So outdated
Jake:他这个设计
Jake: This design
Jake:可能太前卫了
Jake: Might be too avant-garde
Jake:不知道是前卫还是落后
Jake: Not sure if it's avant-garde or outdated
Lucia: 不知道确实不知道
Lucia: Not sure, really not sure
Lucia: 前卫还是落后
Lucia: Avant-garde or outdated
Jake:对他可能是用的电越多
Jake: Yeah, maybe the more power it uses
Jake:他降的就颜色越少
Jake: The fewer colors it shows
Jake:就是就是往下面掉
Jake: It drops down
Lucia: 颜色越少
Lucia: Fewer colors
Jake:他是一个怒气一样的东西
Jake: It's like an anger meter or something
Lucia: 嗯呃
Lucia: Hmm, uh
Jake:有可能
Jake: Maybe
Lucia: 不是就是您的颜色越少的意思
Lucia: No, you mean the fewer colors
Lucia: 这个长度越短还是颜色越浅
Lucia: Does it mean shorter length or lighter color?
Jake:对颜色越浅
Jake: Yeah, lighter color
Jake:呃长度越短
Jake: Uh, shorter length
Lucia: 长度越短
Lucia: Shorter length
Jake:对
Jake: Right
Jake:试试试试
Jake: Try it, try it